so i'm i'm curious if someone has
actually never seen
anything that you've done before what is
the first thing you want them watching
and why
uh what would wow well
that's you you're asking me a question
of like breaking down something into a
21-year career all right let me see um
i've i've worked in
a plethora of genres so i think i would
say
a movie of mine called dildarak nedo
from india
which um i recently did which would be a
good one to start
thank you for the answer um i am a huge
fan of lana's and obviously the
franchise um you've worked with a number
of filmmakers what surprised you about
working with lana that perhaps you
weren't expecting
wow she's um
she's a powerhouse
you know that's a director who knows
exactly what she wants
what surprised me was how hands-on she
is and how
like she'll move you around physically
you know she's thinking on the go she
handles the camera herself um she does
not like rehearsals
she likes everything to be live and
electric and that's
terrifying as an actor because you don't
have any time to prepare
and she doesn't like preparation very
much so that was very surprising it was
um really interesting to come into that
kind of an energy you know and i think
that's why the performances in the
matrix are so electric is because
they're actually happening live
uh on what day of the shoot were you
sitting there looking at keanu or carrie
anne or just you know being on set and
did it hit you i'm in a matrix movie
like because i'm not sure what you you
know what your familiarity was if you
were a huge fan before getting cast
i was i mean i think the matrix was
especially if you're a 90s kid like it
shifted pop culture i think um i
remember being 16 or 17 and watching it
with my friends
and just
being really moved by the magic of it
all and and the the thought processes
that it made you think about so um i i
think when
lana it was really interesting when she
cast me i had flown down from india and
come directly from the airport to meet
her
and after a conversation she asked her
assistant amy to come in with
the script and gave it to me and said
welcome to the matrix and i think that
was the moment where i was like
i have a hot off the presses script of
the matrix and i walked out like that
like you know oh my gosh i need to find
a vault to put it in but um that was the
moment where i was like wow in the
matrix that's cool
i am also incredibly excited for citadel
um which i know you recently filmed or
wrapped on it's
i have actor friends i know that face um
what what can you tease people about
that project and what was it about the
material that said i really want to be a
part of this
um there's nothing like citadel on
television i think you know um i it's
it's high it's extremely high scale
extremely finessed action stunts but at
the same time it ha it's a drama and it
has heart and um
so i think that there's really nothing
like that on tv right now and that was
one of the big reasons why i really
wanted to do it um
doing something for multiple episodes
you know it's a commitment
because this was a limited series
um it was really great we shot it for
over a year it was really physically
very very intense for
um you know my character
and i'm sure for you know a bunch of the
cast as well so it was a lot of work but
i'm so excited to share it with the
world because i just saw a bunch of it
recently and i think it's very special
we've worked really hard on it and you
see that
do you know when it's going to air
we're hoping end of next year maybe got
it i have to wrap there i'm just going
to say great talking with you um i wish
you nothing but the best thank you so
much and happy holidays to you happy
holidays to you thank you
you